hello everyone welcome to simulation we
have a very special day today at Indy
bio they're doing their investor pitches
today it's the demo day Indy bio is the
world's largest seed stage biotechnology
accelerator I've had the privilege of
being a mentor there I love these guys
they are mostly scientists technologists
people that are really trying to
leverage the code of life and
understanding of biology to impact the
world in beautiful new ways what exactly
is an Indian and hit it up
definitely so Vivian is the first
company developing small molecules that
can be combined with a wide range of
both chemo therapies and immunotherapies
in order to make them more effective
treatments for cancer alright so that
means it comes alongside the treatment
so your molecules come alongside the
immunotherapy or the chemotherapy to
make it to do to your visioning a cell
there's a shield around cancer cell and
your molecule enables the is it the
deterioration of that shield essentially
yes our molecules would be given
alongside of chemotherapy or an
immunotherapy to eliminate certain
proteins within cancer cells that stop
chemo and immunotherapies from working
ah
okay so there's proteins inside of cells
that stop chemo therapies and
immunotherapies from working right and
then your molecule targets those
proteins and destroys them yes through a
upstream regulator so instead of going
after one of these proteins directly we
go after an upstream regulatory system
within cells and when we do this we've
creates it's called hippo hippo and so
it's a biochemical pathway within cells
and when we inactivate hippo we
eliminate a range of different proteins
that stop existing treatments from
working awesome awesome so then you have
to know about this biochemical pathway
called hippo and then that biochemical
pathway makes these proteins that
make the sheet to make the shield for
the cancer so essentially that's that's
that's normally in the dude to have that
hippo pathway before what would that
when that protein was expressed was it
also making a shield that or what was it
doing before it became prevented yeah
cancer treatments so hippo is an
established pathway in biology it's very
important in embryonic development plays
a less key role in adult tissue normally
but under cancerous conditions hippo is
a key regulator of a suite of proteins
some of them break chemotherapies down
others stop chemo therapies by throwing
them out of the cancer cell and this new
role for hippo in chemo therapeutic
resistance wasn't known until work by
our collaborator at Harvard Medical
School and we've gone beyond that now to
talk about doing adjuvant treatments
that can be combined with existing
treatments to make them far more
effective nice and so you're right now
in preclinical that's right trials so
what does the pre clinical world look
like so you've made you manufacture this
molecule and is that how does that
manufacturing of the molecule work and
then how do you actually go about
testing and preclinical tell us about
that yeah so we've done a good amount of
target validation both our own and with
our collaborator from Harvard and now
based on that validation we spun out of
Harvard Medical School we've negotiated
exclusive rights to intellectual
property from their filed our own
patents independent of the University
and have begun to say okay now that this
target is validated let's develop small
molecules that inactivate it and to do
that we've formed a couple of different
partnerships one with a contract
research organization that does the bulk
of our chemical development work and the
other a machine learning startup that
applies some of its next-generation
convolutional neural networks to
optimize our compounds and between the
three of us we're hoping to bring the
first potent and selective inhibitors of
this pathway into clinical studies
cool so then you gotta have the right
partner is both the Harvard and the
chemical and was she learning all that
yeah so then what does the manufacturing
of the molecule entail the usual we're
describing the chemical partner how did
you even how do you how does one even
discover a molecule that can inhibit
this pathway yeah so there are millions
of molecules out there already and we
only know what a fraction of them do so
once we had identified and confirmed the
validity of this target and there are
multiple targets within the pathway but
we're starting with just a couple we
took one of those and we said let's
screen hundreds of thousands of these
molecules against this target using both
computational and biochemical tools and
saying here are those compounds that
potently inactivate this target and we
use those as the starting point for a
set of optimization a combination of
machine learning and rational design
done by our lead chemist who's sort of a
traditional medicinal chemist who does
targeted changes to the the molecule we
run those through the CN NS and in this
iterative process we'll be able to
develop more potent and more selective
inhibitors that can then be put through
preclinical trials and go into human
studies great great and then is this for
all cancer so we have a specially strong
validation in pancreatic cancer where
we've shown that we can take the
frontline chemotherapy for this disease
which currently has a very limited
effect in patients and when we give this
to cancer cells in combination with our
intervention our deactivation of this
pathway leads to the dramatic
sensitization of the cancer you can kill
pancreatic cancer cells that were
previously entirely resistant our
collaborator from Harvard Medical School
tested 15 out of sorry tested a hundred
and nineteen chemo therapies and
identified 15 which are used across a
dozen different types of cancer and
showed that in activating this pathway
this target could enable those chemo
therapies to work as well so based on
the drug classes that those came from
and some of our own research at indy bio
we expect this will work with at least
40 different chemo therapies each of
which are used in several different
cancers
it's awesome yeah yeah outside yeah this
is great this is a this is a every
single person I think that I know that's
doing something in the healthcare
industry is almost doing it differently
have you noticed that everybody's doing
things differently yes well you've got
it right otherwise why don't you join
one of the existing ones but they're all
one of them's trying to break down the
shield of the cancerous cell another one
is trying to rejuvenate the parts of the
cell that are that are dying another one
is there's all the people trying to
figure out what the golden key is to the
process so it's really good to learn
across all of you that are all doing the
different things tonight right you know
we wish Navy in the absolute best and do
you anything else that came to mind that
you think would be important to share
about Vivian what you guys are doing
well no I'll just I'll just comment on
your last point because I think this is
a really important thing not just for
our working cancer but every biotech
startup in the field right now which is
the reason you're seeing so many
different exciting approaches is because
there's been a convergence of advances
in biology from the rapidly falling cost
of gene sequencing to the proliferation
of gene editing tools to the rise of the
contract research organization and the
ability to use an existing
infrastructure on a contract basis to do
the type of work that you used to need
millions of dollars to set up your own
infrastructure in order to do these
tools and their dozens of others have
made it possible to do biology much
faster and cheaper than ever before it's
very comparable to the way that you know
tech companies used to require millions
of dollars in databases and servers in
order to get anything done and now you
can start one from your laptop that same
type of revolution is now taking place
in biology and we're just one of the
many efforts that's taking advantage of
that to do something important in the
field thank you so much Nathaniel and we
wish you the absolute best moving
forward and biologies on only at the
beginning of its explosion thanks to
technology
and decreasing the cost of all these
processes yeah thank you very much thank
you so much